la destrucción de la economía y la
destrucción de la democracia
hoy hoy 4 efe
a 30 años de este punto de inflexión en
el que el destino de venezuela se torció
hacia el abismo porque en ese momento
chávez afirmaba estarle dando un golpe
de estado a carlos andrés pérez que era
el presidente demócrata en funciones
pero en realidad le estaba propinando en
un golpe de estado a la democracia
venezolana eso la proceso se ha tardó un
tiempo en darse cuenta de ello pero pero
ese es ese golpe y arremetida contra la
democracia no solamente contra dos
mandatarios
bueno hablemos más de ese panorama que
vivió venezuela hace 30 años porque el
entonces comandante chávez decide dar el
golpe de estado y qué fue lo que falló
pero
chávez
llega a donde llega por un 'mea culpa'
ss 4 de febrero que la sociedad valora
como algo
un gesto hidalgo que aceptaba el fracaso
en una operación militar muy distinto
por cierto a lo que hizo luego ya seis
años después una vez del gobierno que
todo fue más bien evadir culpas pero la
en aquel momento la sociedad y ciertas
élites no solamente justificaron el
golpe sino que en alguna medida
glorificaron a los golpistas la sociedad
en ese momento la sociedad venezolana
asumía la democracia como una condición
base a la que tenía pleno derecho y la
realidad se encargó de demostrar que
nunca se puede dar a la democracia por
descontado que la democracia necesita
mucho mimo
está en continuo
transformación y en continua
y enriquecimiento de las condiciones
bueno y qué pasó con chávez tras aceptar
su responsabilidad cuál fue la imagen
que quedó entre los venezolanos
si efectivamente
como ustedes lo han dicho
chávez fue mucho mejor político de
militar que militar fracasó en se vuelve
militar pero triunfó el golpe político
[Música]
en aquel momento también en ese año y
curiosamente hubo un libro muy potente y
unas ideas muy potentes las de william
en ese libro que se llamó el fin de la
historia del último hombre según la cual
el mundo estaba evolucionando hacia o en
una dirección donde el último hombre era
demócrata y capitalista chávez en ese
año se había demostrado que no era ni
democrático ni capitalista y no era
solamente un lugar dentro de esa
tendencia general sino que fue precursor
de algo que se convertiría después en
una tendencia decreciente que es esos
rasgos del populismo autoritario que
aparecieron primeramente en chalets pero
que luego se han encargado de ir
apareciendo en otras partes del mundo en
esta era que vivimos hoy que es la era
de una recesión
democrática global creo que en 1992
también fue un punto de inflexión en ese
particular y un cierto impacto que lo
cual bueno con la situación actual con
lo que está pasando y con lo que ha
pasado en los últimos años posible que
se produzca un nuevo golpe de estado en
venezuela
cuando las condiciones
objetivas que existían en ese entonces
eran mucho mejores a las a las que
existen hoy lo que pasa es que si en
venezuela no se ha producido aún un
golpe de estado es porque se trata de un
régimen militar o sea se trata de unos
militares que están sosteniendo al
régimen de nicolás maduro esa esa es la
realidad
por eso no no no
no es no son claras las posibilidades de
un golpe estaba un indicador clarísimo y
que quizás en el mar
entonces el del producto migratorio neto
es el peor de los muchos indicadores de
estos 30 años señora fernández a ustedes
muchas gracias por su análisis y a
ustedes por su sintonía